hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
seeing all your weeks going how was your
week going hey hey hey hey how's it
going hey how about those [ __ ] red
socks i won 28 last night
seems impressive and then you look and
they gave up seven runs in the ninth
inning we're up 20 to one
they had one and three quarter grand
slams i guess in the ninth inning i
don't know what happened but i'll tell
you why the red sox won i'll tell you
why because they dug deep
because they didn't get down on
themselves
and most importantly because i didn't
watch the game
i literally feel like it jinx
i've been watching them since the last
devil raised series
right
where we got swept
and i've missed they've won three games
they won one game against detroit they
won one game against toronto and they
won last night i've watched every other
[ __ ] game
so i think it's me
getting superstitious man you get
superstitious when your team loses when
your team's winning you don't give a
[ __ ] you're walking all around the room
you know what i mean you're sticking
your head in you don't give a [ __ ] you
go out in the oil get yourself a roast
beef sandwich
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing but when
they're losing you're just sitting there
watching the game
afraid to shift your weight if they're
up by [ __ ] two runs
that's how i've been so uh
what a crazy game
three in the first inning two in the
second inning five in the fourth
four in the fifth
[ __ ] game's over that's that's 14 to
nothing 14 to one
and then they score six runs
in the eighth to be up 20 to one and
then they give up seven runs
in the top of the ninth
jesus christ but whatever a [ __ ] win
is a win and it's against the god damn
devil race
down there in goddamn tampa bay
where the devil runs amok
and but they won't call their team the
devil raised they call them the raise we
don't we don't want the devil
in there
that's why that franchise has never won
the world series
you know what i mean because their
ownership
is just so trying to get people to come
to the game that if a small fraction of
people are like we don't like devil in
the name
okay we shouldn't be glorified it's the
name
of a [ __ ] fish you dumb [ __ ]
don't call here anymore
i don't give a [ __ ] if you don't you're
not going to the game
you've never gone to a game and we're
doing fine we don't need you
oh you're telling me you went to a game
well what the [ __ ] you went to a game
and it was called devil raised you
survived right then what's the [ __ ]
problem
you [ __ ] record the conversation [ __ ]
you
goodbye
that's what they should have said
yeah they get in trouble yeah they get
some sort of stupid ass fine for telling
somebody to go [ __ ] themselves on their
phone
right
which i don't know why you sh well it's
just all about money because they got to
put a show on
uh what the ownership of the devil race
said to that stupid lady who never goes
to games anyways that was uh it's not
what we're about
it's not uh what we represent and it's
uh nothing that we want to be a part of
we had a long top with uh uh johnny
owner of the devil raised excuse me the
raise
i misspoke
can we edit that out we can't this is
live okay then i'm gonna apologize live
i'm sorry
is anybody watching this that's the
[ __ ] world we live in
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are so afraid to
have one nickel roll out the door they
gotta literally change the name
of their team that's named after a
[ __ ] stingray
sting ray those both sound violent
can we just call them like the razors
you know like you shave your face with
well some people slit their wrists with
razors that's a great point
can we call them the
tampa bay
puffers
um
anyway very excited and that they they
won
and uh
i guess what i will i won't watch him
and then i'll just watch the replay
um
but i've been having the best week i'm
back here in boston and um
staying out on the water man it's just
been [ __ ] great
and uh you know this is where i'm from i
need to come back here more often i can
tell you that
[ __ ] spend like a month out here
maybe not a month i would be afraid if i
spent a month out here i'd move back
be like you know what hey you know [ __ ]
it
i'll just do some local shows here i'll
[ __ ]
call up dick doherty get it going again
um
but last night we did the uh
the memorial slash
stand-up comedy comics reunion
uh for the late great wayne previty and
uh i cannot tell you how [ __ ] nervous
i was for this night
i invited a bunch of comics
that we all started out at the same time
wayne did back in like 1992
and a lot of us had not seen each other
in a long long time and certainly we had
not all been together in the same room
so
uh i didn't know if it was gonna be
awkward if it was gonna be weird it was
gonna be sad like wow we're all old you
know i didn't know what it was gonna be
like
and um
it was it was [ __ ] magical man it was
everything that i wanted to happen like
the comics didn't even get to their
dressing rooms it was just everyone was
standing out in the hall
telling stories laughing hugging giving
each other [ __ ]
another thousand stories talking about
wayne it was just um
it was absolutely [ __ ]
perfect and um the lineup on the show
was basically
you know
this was essentially an open mic show
that was booked 30 years ago that we'd
you know had john david host and john
david was always you know
he ran the uh the 99 in bell ricker
and um
[Music]
just a crazy crazy dude
like i thought he was the coolest guy
when i met him because he told me he
goes i've never had a real job i go what
do you mean i go he goes these have been
my job he was a professional roller
skater if you can believe that in the
late 70s and roller skating was huge he
had like a sponsor and all of that until
he did some sort of triple lindy thing
and he blew out his elbow then he was a
drummer and a band
and then he was a stand-up comedian i
mean that's about his
[ __ ]
that's a dynasty
of of not
having to go to work or feeling like
you're at work
um that we had jack lynch
now jack lynch
hosted the first time old freckles here
ever bombed
on stage it was this place kelly's pub
in north reading massachusetts
and it was in either the end of march or
the beginning of april in 1992 it was my
third show
i started march 2nd at knicks comedy
stop and then i did one in stitches a
few weeks later
and then i did my first satellite room a
bar and i went in there and oh my god it
was the first time i told the joke and
it got nothing
and i felt that [ __ ]
concussive emotional
force to my chest and oh dude i imploded
i was supposed to do five minutes i
bailed after like two
i don't know what i did i literally said
on the microphone i said hey jack i'm
bailing
and i was so embarrassed i wanted to
leave but i just sat down on the first
seat available
which is right up near the stage because
i i couldn't face the comedians because
when i said i was bailing i heard the
community like ah come on man like you
know which was a great thing they were
trying to encourage me but all i heard
was disappointment
and i just sat there like a scolded
child to the end of the show
and um
i remember you know and that was the
first night i ever met wayne previtty
he came in and closed
he had his track suit on he had one of
his friends said this is my manager you
got to talk to him you know he's sort of
like a
dice clay-like vibe uh then we had todd
parker
who was on the show
um
todd parker was the first time i ever
did stand-up uh was at nix like i said
and it was a comedy competition
and they had some of the local comics
judge
uh the comics to see who was the best
and uh he was one of the judges
and uh so i've known that guy basically
since day one of doing stand-up joey
carroll
um part of my graduation class uh used
to be obsessed with death his whole act
was talking about death uh dane cook you
guys might have heard he was the special
guest
he came up and ripped it everybody
killed by the way which was awesome uh
and dan smith like i think my first open
mic my second show i met him um along
with tony moschetto
uh at stitches comedy club
and then i uh went on and mopped up in
the end and everybody had a great set
everybody [ __ ] killed
um and todd parker put together this
great
video of wayne with all of these
pictures my wife went out and watched it
i had already seen it i didn't want to
get all emotional before i went out
there and be all the [ __ ] sad clown
so um there was a clip of me in it
you know at an angels game this infamous
angels game that we all went to
um
[Music]
and i had no beard and a full head of
hair and people were watching it having
no idea who i was and my wife said it
took him a second then they were like oh
[ __ ] that's bill with hair
um
so uh
dave mclaughlin nick costas a bunch of
comics came out that didn't you know we
just didn't even have time to put him up
jimmy q
um
it was just uh it was just literally
like the perf then it was a guy spike
tobin
who came out he was in the crowd
and we were actually talking i was like
man i forgot to invite spike you know it
was so many guys you know that i reached
out to and
that were uh
you know either not available or you
know
i don't know what just too far away bob
sheehy got to make sure i remember
everybody's name
uh bob carney
uh
and then mike pryor couldn't make it you
[ __ ] next on the next one but we
just had the best time
magical [ __ ] night so i want to thank
everybody involved my clock came out
from giggles
i mean and then afterwards downstairs
at the wilbur now there's a club
downstairs and i ordered uh
a bunch of chinese food from the golden
temple in brighton
uh recommendation from a friend of mine
and everybody said the [ __ ] chinese
food was great and we just sat there
just like
just chowing this [ __ ] especially the
guys who don't live in uh
massachusetts anymore
we had spare ribs crab ragu it was
[ __ ] awesome so i got to go on a nice
old man walk along the beach
which is what i've been doing and i'm
really getting taken by the ocean now
man i think i'm actually going to go
swimming in it i've just seen too many
old guys
i mean i'm talking old like 20 years
older than me hey you know you're old
when you're 20 years older than me
and uh they got a little [ __ ] paddle
thing kayak that i said i wasn't gonna
use and i'm like you know what [ __ ] it
nice upper body workout
i'll slather on you see the sunblock i
use i literally look like i have pancake
batter on me like i'm gonna do a kabuki
[ __ ] show or something
um
so anyway it was just a [ __ ] awesome
night and uh i really want to thank
everybody once again that was involved
in that
and uh it's been a long time coming
wayne passed away unfortunately a little
over a year ago because of this [ __ ]
kovic [ __ ] trying to do the show was
difficult so um
very happy uh
to do that so
that's it other than that i've been
taking old man walks along the beach
um
like a uh
i don't know i looked up like how long
it takes to walk 10 000 steps because
what am i going to sit there and count
them they said it was about 5 miles
and you can do it in about an hour
if you're [ __ ] upset dude i can't
walk five miles in an hour
i'm not doing that [ __ ] so how about i
walk for like an hour and 15 minutes all
right i know if i walk sort of briskly
you know i can walk a mile in 15 minutes
you know i mean what's that
4.0
on the uh
on the treadmill so i just been doing
that
you know keeping the weight off
i haven't really put anything on
while i've been out here and uh just
been having a blast with the kids and
everything they're loving the beach
going down there um
yesterday one of my daughter's cousins
taught her how to skim a rock
and she came in she's like hey dad i
want to go to the beach tomorrow and
throw rocks i'm like oh my god this is
like
friggin perfect we went to a uh
went to some one of those clam
[ __ ] shacks out here
got the uh clam bellies with the french
fries
it's all that classic i've yet to get a
bar pizza i got to get a roast beef
sandwich
um i got chinese food
i got to make sure i get all the uh
classic
new england uh cuisine out here but uh i
can't tell you man how much i [ __ ]
miss being out here
i really really love this part of the uh
country
and um
you know if my kids weren't so damn
young and in school and [ __ ] you know
you know i wasn't in this stupid ass
business i would move back here in a
second but i'm thinking of getting like
one of these little [ __ ] get a
cottage dude
just get some little [ __ ] place you
know
like some two three room thing
near the water just coming out here for
like a month every year because i gotta
be honest with you man i've been back
here and i've haven't been last night i
was sitting out you know
after the show and the after party at
all excited that it went so well
um
just sitting in like a sun chair on this
porch listening to the waves i was just
like i don't think i've been this
[ __ ] relaxed in like two years
so i am totally sold on it um
i haven't lived here in a long long i
was thinking you know the last time i
lived here the red sox
played in fenway there was nothing on
the green monster they didn't have all
that added [ __ ] [ __ ] out in right
field
you know you could like walk around the
ballpark during the game they didn't
have it all closed off like the [ __ ]
president was in town
the bruins were still playing at the
boston garden and the patriots in
celtics were at boston garden the red
sox was still at sullivan stadium
um
so
anyway the big thing going on right now
is i've been having this this big debate
with my daughter where i keep trying to
tell her
that there's more than one spider-man
song
and she's trying to tell me that's not
the one you know because i'm like
spider-man spider-man does whatever
spider-man spins a web any size and when
i was a kid
um i thought it said catch his fleas
just like flies
i wasn't the brightest kid catches these
chests like flabs look out
here comes the spider-man and that's the
only one that i knew
and i knew the end you find the
spider-man i never knew the rest of it
i like the [ __ ] that they talk in the
second verse is he strong listen bud
he's got radioactive blood it's like
[ __ ] relaxed man it was a fair
question
you know can he swing from a thread take
a look overhead hey there
there goes the spider-man and they got a
nice little bridge in the chill of the
night at the scene of the crime like a
streak of light he arrives just in time
spider-man spider-man friendly
neighborhood spider-man
i like this part here where he's just
[ __ ] badass
listen to this
wealth and fame he's ignored
i didn't know all the yeah he didn't
[ __ ] himself out like bruce wayne
[ __ ] trust fun kid
wealth and fame he's ignored action is
his reward to him life's a great big
bang up wherever there's a hang up
you'll find the spiderman
he's got radioactive blood he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the [ __ ] horse
you know
he just likes [ __ ] going around
beating up bad people i mean what's not
to like
it's not to like
i like you know who who came up with the
whole uh you know when he came when he
wears the black suit then all of a
sudden he's like an [ __ ] he's like a
bad guy
who came up with that first was it
hollywood hulk hogan
or was it spider-man
um
because i gotta tell you man i i
what was what happened to when he had
the uh
the black suit
he would get like he'd sort of get like
drunk with power
you know he was sort of like you know
joking around and [ __ ] when he had the
red and blue one
and then he put on the black one and
like someone would talk he's like [ __ ]
i wasn't talking to you
just shut the [ __ ] up and he'd shoot
some uh spider webs on
[ __ ]
disgusting you know he had his little
moment you know
well thank god he had the black suit pre
like you know 2017 or he would have got
like me too for toxic behavior
um all right so anyways version
convinced me to take a [ __ ] dip in
the ocean
he's like oh you got to do it you got to
do it bill i'm telling you
in the salt water over
it's over it's like all right i said but
you know what dude if i get bit by a
[ __ ] shark i swear to god
i swear to god
you know
but um
i sat there yesterday in the same sun
chair i just sat on this porch and i
watched this old couple go out there
during low tide which by the way i
thought i thought it you know
it was high tide and low tide like once
during the day
but i've realized that uh it goes out it
comes in it goes out
it comes back in it's like twice a day
unless i'm crazy
um because last night i couldn't see it
was dark out it sounded like the waves
were right up uh right up on the beach
um
but anyway
that's what the [ __ ] i'm gonna do so the
red sox win a big game they got a game
this afternoon i'm gonna sit here and
i'm gonna watch this [ __ ]
and uh
i don't know i don't know why i'm having
such a good time back here it's probably
because i don't have any gigs or
anything
man i got one tomorrow night i had one
last night but like
there's nobody like calling me i got
like nothing to do i mean
i could you know the reality is i could
be in arkansas right now and having a
great i can [ __ ] move out here you go
anywhere and you're on vacation you
don't have anything to do you're like
dude this [ __ ] place is great
you know you don't realize that
everybody around you has to go to work
and you're just sitting there like this
is amazing
dude i love arkansas i get up at 10
o'clock in the morning
nobody's bugging me
dude i got to tell you something
underrated alaska
um all right let's do some reads here
for this week oh look who it is
everybody
look who it is it's all legalzoom
everybody you know according to forbes
gyms
nail salons hotels mom and pop stores
and more are set to go on an epic hiring
spree in the coming months to meet the
pent-up demand for all of these services
isn't that exciting
talk about any business that you were
especially excited to return to or that
you've already returned to i'd say
hawkinsburger in watts
and uh any gyms specifically the
bodybuilder gym
uh in silver lake these are some of the
mom-and-pop places
comedians have been trying to help out
um i miss going to a spa
i used to be a steam room guy
until i went over to rogan's and he said
dude you got to do the sauna because the
sonic because it's a dry heat you can go
a lot harder you can you can you can um
sweat out more toxins movie theaters who
doesn't want to go to a movie theater
you know check out the latest flick
um
concert venues comedy shows
all of that [ __ ]
i miss all of that uh all of these
businesses are reopening you know what
that means that means that millions of
jobs will need to be filled so
where do these businesses turn to to
fill these roles
sorry fast
i've needed to sneeze this whole podcast
um you know where they go old zip
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
when you post a job on zip
they send you uh they send your job to
over 100 top job sites giving you access
to their network of millions of job
seekers
yeah
matching matching technology scans
resumes
resin resumes resumes jesus bill
wait isn't that how you spell resumes
hang on a second well let me finish the
copy that'll look it up
how to spell resume verse resume
okay zip recruiters matching technology
scans resumes to find qualified
candidates for your open roles and
proactiv proactively
presents them to you
you can easily
review recommend
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply
for your job which encourages them to
apply
faster
according to zip recruit it's internal
data
or is it data i don't know
jobs
where employers invite candidates to
apply get two and a half more times
uh
more candidates can i read that whole
sentence over again can i get a mulligan
on that according to zip
internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates
see how much more interesting did that
sound zip
rip
technology is so effective that four to
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day and right now you
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive website
ziprecruiter.com that zip
just go to
ziprecruiter.com ziprecruiter
the smartest way to hire
um all right well one of the big things
when you're like me and you go for old
man walks uh is you got to make sure
that you stretch guys are you out there
are you stretching
you know what i'd ask the ladies if you
guys are stretching too but you know i
don't you know i try to avoid women now
every little thing seems to upset him
and set him off
right and then you [ __ ] lose your
goddamn career so i'm i'm you know i got
my wife i talked to her i just [ __ ]
everybody else like hey
i give them the wave
little [ __ ]
it's but it's not a wave back and forth
it's it's so the hand goes from goes
from left to right it's a it's just a
flip like a [ __ ] like i'm
you know
like go down that way looks like a wave
but it's also like you know
it could also be you know stay away from
me
stay away from me i like my life i like
my life the way it is
you know
eating some [ __ ] clams and some
french fries and uh
i don't know what you're upset about but
i'm sure it's something
and uh i'm sure it has something to do
with your [ __ ] childhood and now
you're gonna blame me you know i wasn't
even there
i just happened to be here on the
[ __ ] wrong time
the wrong date or whatever
and i ran into you when you had your
goddamn axe to grind
oh jesus christ i gotta stop talking
politics by the way
these [ __ ] [ __ ] on the news sites
all of a sudden they're like paying
attention to me like i actually read
my favorite one was these [ __ ] dopes
at the huffington post those [ __ ]
wishy-washy [ __ ] they tried to cancel
me twice
then all of a sudden i say something
about some guy with a red tie and
they're like oh he said dude no now you
like me
[ __ ] horse
um
anyway
plowing ahead plowing ahead
i probably shouldn't have said that
because now some douches who just wear
red ties will they'll be like oh now he
said this
i mean i can barely name the 50 states i
don't know why anybody would pay
attention to me
um
all right so last night i was uh
i was going to bed and my wife was
watching all these tick tock videos
which i really like i really like tik
tok but for the life of me i just can't
figure out you know oh no i downloaded
the app and then just wanted all of this
information
like it used to be if you didn't have
tick tock they would still play the
video now the video plays and it's on
mute
you know
so at that point it's just like all
right you know what i'll just watch it
on my wife's phone i'm not
i think enough people got my information
out there i don't need to be signing up
for your crap
although tick-tock is perfect as far as
like
you know
videos that i should short
they're funny a lot of funny [ __ ]
videos out there i saw somebody like
dressed up like bigfoot dancing around
who would think something as simple as
that
acting out a song would be funny
i just don't like those uh
those cooking videos
there's so many amateur cooks out there
that have no idea what the [ __ ] they're
doing
and their thing is like
they make emerald lugosi look like
understated
because i remember when that guy first
came out it was like this guy is out of
his [ __ ] mind
because he was taking like all of these
standard like
dishes that you knew
and where everybody else would stop he
would keep adding [ __ ] for like another
10 minutes bam we're gonna kick it up
another notch right
he'd had extra chocolate chips or
something remember he's making like
those [ __ ] uh hello dolly bars
um what do we call them or a coconut
dream bar as they were called at the
bakery
uh
that i went into one time
and he added a whole other extra layer
of chocolate chip at this point they
make him look like he cooks in a bland
way
i saw this thing the other [ __ ] day
this guy made a a uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] he was making
but it was just like just stop
stop
that whole [ __ ]
having a savory thing that you add some
sugary [ __ ] to and then they go back to
the salt
and then they're always [ __ ] like
some balsamic vinaigrette no stick a
pickle on there some mayonnaise
you know my wife was watching one this
woman was just like you know this is
what i do
you know she has like the keto thing so
anything that you have that isn't bread
she just turns it into bread
like a pepper or a pickle or a kumquat
she just uses that for bread and after a
while it's just like you're just making
the same dish over and over again
we had this you guys and it was so
delicious try it out and tell me if you
like it why am i [ __ ] on her she's
got a dream i'm sorry
and then she watches those ones where
it's just the sound of sizzling and
cutting and all of that and i swear to
god it's like nails going down a [ __ ]
chalkboard
um
whatever we were watching that thing
last night by the way my wife last night
might have been the funniest person
there
just was just [ __ ] on everybody in a
funny way
she goes hey bill could you have booked
any more middle-aged white guys on this
show
and it was just like this is what the
comedy scene was
it was a [ __ ] sausage fest it was it
was all white guys
and like patrice
until dwayne perkins came along
it was carl yard i think
um
who else was up here
there wasn't a lot it was just it was
just a bunch of white guys going dude
what the [ __ ] with the snow it's
[ __ ] snowing every other [ __ ] day
up here jesus christ my balls are
[ __ ] turning blue that's all it was
that's all boston comedy was was a bunch
of [ __ ] white guys so we represented
it
i kept it real it was all white there
was not one ounce of diversity on the
show
um anyway that's the podcast i got to go
for my little old man walk go red sox
the new england patriots have their uh
first preseason game tonight
uh imagine that uh that quarterback i
don't even know his name yet the kid
from alabama is going to get a couple of
snaps we'll see how he looks
you know
who knows
did bill belichick pull it off again
patriots
qb
uh jared
stidham
is who we got and of course we got cam
newton too uh
but we'll see what's going on here
no disrespect to cam newton i mean jesus
christ
what am i doing here but i don't we're
all excited we're all excited we got you
know we drafted a you know what's more
exciting than you when your team picks a
quarterback
as a high draft pick
i don't know bill when they grab a sixth
rounder who wins [ __ ] seven super
bowls and becomes the greatest qb of all
time yeah that is pretty exciting
um
you know he won six for us and then went
down to tampa where they're afraid of
the stingrays and they uh he won another
one there and i hope he wins if we don't
[ __ ] win it this year
right
which where anytime there's bill
belichick you got to think you got a
chance
uh if we don't win it this year i'm
rooting for tampa i am
i'm not that [ __ ] i'm not that guy who
gets all upset that somebody [ __ ]
left
um
we got a whole we got a giant stadium
with the lighthouse in it because of
that guy
all right that's it everybody that is
the podcast um i hope i gave you a
couple of laughs on this thing i know a
lot of it was just me reminiscing but um
i really i really can't thank the people
i didn't think the crowd that showed up
we raised so much money for the american
uh
heart association and uh the crowd was
was was so just awesome we just had a
[ __ ] great time and um
and that's what rayne previty was he was
a great time he's just a great guy a
great person to hang around with um
and uh yeah i still can't believe the
guy's gone but um
you know it's one of those shitty things
in life you know so all right now i'm
gonna get set [ __ ] that all right
uh
have a great weekend you [ __ ] listen to
the music and we have a bonus episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast i will
talk to you
one two three
morning
podcast
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
august 12
2013 how you doing how'd you like that
intro
wasn't that pretty cool
that was actually uh you're probably
going who were those fine singers
jesus christ that was was was that just
human beings doing that by themselves no
autotune
was kanye west not in there with a
leather [ __ ] skirt on singing about
getting his dicks up despite the fact he
just had a baby daughter
um
ah [ __ ] one of my ears is ringing i hate
when this happens anybody else have
hearing damage
come on stop ringing
um
every once in a while one of my ears
just goes
and then it [ __ ] you know
like some heavy metal singer from
[ __ ] decades ago
like saying remember your childhood your
acid washed jeans anyways that was the
members of our truth and salvage company
um i got to know those guys uh
i was getting who through boozing
i met that drummer bill smith i was out
on a drunken night
and he came over to me and he said hey
hey uh my name is bill oh so why don't
you tone it down you freckled [ __ ]
and i had to respect him
no i'm kidding um they have a new album
out called uh pick me up that's
available on itunes and a new single
called appalachian hilltop if you
actually like human beings
if you like
if you like yeah if you like some sort
of heartbeat in like your music at this
point you know not saying that you guys
out there on your designer drugs eating
each other's faces watching some guy
with the mouse head and your glow sticks
is not a good time
you know if i got sucked into heavy
metal you know when i when i was uh
coming up in the 80s if i was coming up
now i would [ __ ] i'd probably be
there
i definitely would be
i'd sit there jumping up and down in
unison as that guy played his stereo
some club
um am i doing the thing that all old
people do
i get fearful and i'm just trashing all
the new stuff
i was reading something recently when um
when airplanes first came out actually
believe it or not people sometimes i do
read
and i was reading this book about when
airplanes first came out and uh
this guy was pitching we basically all
we had we had like
we had the army in the navy and that was
it
and this somebody in one of those
branches because i already [ __ ]
forget because every other word reminds
me of something in my life and i just
start thinking you know
tom sawyer got on a boat i remember i
got on a boat yeah remember that dinghy
in that kid's pool party and i flipped
over and i got trapped underneath and
then my eyes keep going and like six
pages go by and i have no [ __ ] idea
what i read
um
so i can't remember the guy's [ __ ]
name and i think we just had an army in
a navy at this point
and this was i don't know in the teens
maybe the 20s
of la i'll just say last century as
opposed to people try to confuse you and
go the 20th century
you know
the 18th century
1800s was the 19th century you got to do
that [ __ ] carry the one [ __ ] last
century
all right
and he he basically said to the army in
the navy he was like hey man like these
planes man they're going to like change
[ __ ] and like i don't know if you guys
are going to be ready for it man and all
the old guys were like
go [ __ ] yourself your goddamn kleenex
and your dental floss and your little
lawnmower motor that you have in that
thing engine right
[ __ ] you what are you gonna do to make
my ironsides over here
so he's like well listen man like i
don't really want to
take it to that level but why don't you
put one of your bad ass boats out there
and we'll bring our [ __ ] planes over
let's see what happens so they said all
right so they're sitting there laughing
at them and [ __ ] and they got this
[ __ ] thing that's like six
i don't know it's really thick and it's
really hard to sink
and they keep me
engines and they sank the [ __ ] in like
like 12 minutes
and there was actually
navy admirals crying
they couldn't believe it
um
they were out of a [ __ ] job they
thought
so anyways
is that what i'm doing when it comes to
like dubstack
that [ __ ] like i guess i should be into
it i don't know i like these guys truth
and salvage company i i
they have my stamp of approval if it
means anything i saw them when they
opened uh
for the black crows
where the [ __ ] were we somewhere in la i
don't know what so i don't know if you
like that kind of music give these guys
a shot if you're into other kinds of
music just keep listening to that [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] but i don't need to
hear your [ __ ] reviews of it okay
i'm just suggesting
this is how defensive
being on twitter makes you because no
matter what you suggest
you could just say something simple
simply like you know ice cream is
delicious
and then what kind of flavor you get
actually that's not all natural you know
the [ __ ] simone's invented it you
know and you just got to deal with these
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this is coming from a [ __ ]
all right so whatever
i feel bad because i only mentioned bill
smith in the band and i probably just
[ __ ] created a bunch of infighting in
their van
right if you're in a [ __ ] band you
got to be riding around in a van don't
you
isn't that how it works
um anyways
let's plow ahead shall we people i am i
am still here in new orleans
as you can tell the quality of this
podcast the audio the audio at the very
least
okay
is uh is much better than last week's
because the lovely nia actually sent out
my power strip or the cord whatever the
[ __ ] you call it
and um so at least you can hear me
at least you can hear the attempts
you can hear the big swing and a miss
hey i got to tell you something i
actually was actually rooting for alex
rodriguez this week
you know
i really was not because i like the guy
not because i'm all of a sudden the
[ __ ] yankee fan
the bed bath and beyond of the major
league baseball community
um
i just realized yeah their uniforms look
like towels
very nice towels but towels nonetheless
i'm sorry i'm drinking some water here i
burned my tongue it's not the [ __ ]
worst
i actually i ordered room service i got
a grilled cheese and tomato soup as all
people do
and um
i uncovered the tomato soup which was
way too [ __ ] hot
and i had the grilled cheese there so
i'm an american i can't just eat the
grilled cheese i got to take that
grilled cheese and i got to dunk it into
the [ __ ] piping hot tomato soup
so i stick it in my [ __ ] pie hole big
bite of that [ __ ] it's lava hot
so i what do i do i use my brain
my brain says hey bill that's like uh
you're not gonna have much tongue left
if we don't do something about this how
about grabbing something cold
so my right hand was like oh i got this
and reached over to that nice ice cold
glass of water
but the
they had plastic on top of it cellophane
so it wouldn't spill when the lovely
lady brought it up to the room
so
my right hand's like you know this ain't
gonna [ __ ] work and then the rest of
my body went into panic mode and i went
and i just spit out spit it out
instantly
i thought it was actually a smart move
but i immediately started laughing
thinking that that would have been the
greatest vine ever
or one of a nice one anyways
is bill burr eats uh burns tongue
is that it was i mean you know can you
actually do a vine where it's actually
just one thing it's not a bunch of [ __ ]
spliced together
actually i know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about i'm just saying i burn my
goddamn tongue all right people just
trying to tell a story
i [ __ ] puked that thing out like like
you ever see a snake when it's in the
middle of eating and all of a sudden you
walk up to it and it's like oh [ __ ] i
think i'm going to get eaten and then it
just sort of opens its mouth
and that yak comes out of it
and then the snake sitting like now
what's up huh you want to do this
um
basically
walking up to a snake while it's eating
is like what happened to me when i went
to that buffalo bills game with my
patriots hat on and they waited till i
was taking a piss
all right
with my johnson out and then they pushed
me in the back because that's what they
do up there
in the city of lights
other than eating their [ __ ] wings
and losing super bowls they wait till
you got your dick out in buffalo don't
ever forget that
all right so when you go up there the
falls over there in niagara
all right and all of a sudden you get
that sensation that you got to take a
piss looking at all the water
just know
that the great grandson of joe de la
miller whatever the [ __ ] you said his
name
you know fred smirless jr my [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the back is all i'm saying
all right
not trying to cause any static
with that great city
formerly great city that city that will
rise again
like cleveland
like detroit
like des moines
um ever tell you guys how much i love
those cities
i like them i'm a fan of architecture
and when i go there i always just look
and i'm like this eventually this
[ __ ] place is going to blow up
in a good way i mean that in a hip-hop
kind of way look at me
look at me straddling the fence of my
whiteness
um
this is another sign that i'm getting
old i have a real problem with that new
kanye west album that you know cause
i want to settle down and be a [ __ ]
parent and all that type of [ __ ] so i
look up to other people
that finally [ __ ] do it and i'm
thinking oh
is this guy gonna you know is he gonna
be changed somehow with this new [ __ ]
album and it's just still
talking about losing his diamond ring in
some girl's snatch isn't that what it's
all about
i don't know
sometimes i'm glad i look the way i look
and i was never able to enter the club
scene other than to be ushered quickly
back out the
side door
um
anyways
what are we talking about here uh this
is the monday morning podcast and um
i hope you're having a nice august
the summer's coming to a close but you
know this is the golden age of global
warming
water's a little warmer it's just
starting to tickle your toes
but you don't have to worry about
getting eaten by a shark yet
in your [ __ ] living room so you know
i think you might get an extra three
weeks three weeks of the summer
you know what's the greatest is the uh
football season is starting and you know
i've become a huge college football fan
over the years
and i actually realized that my lsu
tigers my adopted
okay before anybody in baton rouge gets
mad at me like man you ain't from here
you ain't from here hope you call them
your tiger there are tigers
um because that's what everyone in the
south sounds like to me
all right whether you do or you don't
you do
in between my ringing ears
evidently they're starting their season
and their guess who they're playing
guess who's back in my life
come on frogs
they're playing
they're playing those jackasses
on the kickoff day i know alabama's
playing somebody else
uh i don't know who the [ __ ] they're
playing
alabama can you believe those you see
what those [ __ ] did this week you see
what they did to [ __ ] the aggies
you know that came from them that
horseshit about
johnny manziel signing [ __ ]
you know that came from an alabama
booster you know it did you know it
you know why
you know i think it came from them
because they're [ __ ] scared
they're scared that sk that skinny
[ __ ] is gonna run all around the
field like the white michael vick all
right and he's gonna [ __ ] beat their
asses again
i actually saw the replay at the end of
the game last year where uh
jesus christ
you never saw sadder looking faces when
they cut to the stands after that
interception right down there in the end
zone
tremendous oh look at that i'm looking
out on the mississippi river there goes
a paddle boat well those tom sawyer ones
you know
way back in the day when food was fresh
and everybody was dropping the n-word
every other word right
we were exterminating the indians oh
what a beautiful piece of history
um
all right what am i doing here is it
time to do a little uh little
advertising would you say well i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm in control of this thing all right
i'm running i'm running this
[ __ ] all right dollar shave club
everybody you know there are so many
things in this world that irritate me
canadians fans script tattoos
people who get to the front of the line
and shoot the [ __ ] with the ticket agent
rather than just getting their [ __ ]
id out and getting on the goddamn plane
right
with so many things like in the world
that irritate you why would you let
razors add to it
what i'm trying to say is stop milking
your razor blade
okay i know you
i know what the brand name razors are
this is gonna be a bad week of reading
come on bill pull it together
it's the first quarter all right we
already burned a timeout let's [ __ ]
get on with it man
um i know with brand name razors you're
used to paying outrageous prices and
exhausting those rage razors until they
start to look like rusty soda cans
let it go it's time to move on dollar
shave club delivers amazing quality
blades to your door for just a few bucks
a month never think about it again
they send a pack every month for just a
few bucks you can change your blades
every week trust me your face will love
you for it
um i'm using it right now you should do
it too if you want to i'm not trying to
force you to do anything
all right if you want to keep shaving
with that
that rusty thing go ahead do it it's
your face
um join dollar shave club shave time
shave money you get it go to
dollarshaveclub.com
that's
dollarshaveclub.com click on the dollar
shave banner at the podcast page
billboard.com
and also are you like me do you like
watching tv but you want to watch it on
your own damn time hulu plus everybody
it's the best way to do it i'm sure
you've tried hulu.com but i want to tell
you about hulu plus
the next level the first class if you
will
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere
streaming on your tv i'll go with you on
your smartphone or tablet why stand in
line or ride a train and just stare at
your feet or maybe chat up some girl and
get laid why would you want to do that
when you could be watching your favorite
shows on hulu plus
hulu plus is a great way to binge watch
your favorite shows hulu plus has tons
of episodes from great comedies like snl
community modern family south park
family guy and thousands of other shows
and guess what hulu plus is only 7.99 a
month that's 7.99 for all the shows and
movies you can watch catch up on current
shows binge on an old favorite or catch
a great movie you can do it all where on
hulu plus right now you can try hulu
plus for a couple of weeks free
on me when you go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and you click on the hulu
plus banner or go to huluplus.com bill
please make sure you use huluplus.com
bills you get an extended free trial and
so they know that i sent you it helps us
keep the lights on and gives you a
better deal one more time for the
extended free trial huluplus.com
bill oh look at me
starting off slow coming back killing
those reads
um
all right where the hell am i
let's get back to the podcast um got a
big couple of weeks coming up everybody
i want to thank everyone who went out
and bought tickets
for uh the show i'm doing co-headlining
with brian regan who's kidding kitten
who i'm opening for the guy
um we're doing a show at cops comedy
club it is all sold out and uh the money
is going to charity
and uh i can't wait to do it brian's um
been
one of the uh
i don't know
how long i've been doing this 21 years
i've been a huge fan of that guy since
the first time i saw him and i've never
got to work with him in this capacity so
i'm really really excited about doing
this and uh
i'm actually also really interested to
see how his fans react to me and my
filth um
all right so that's that's on august
27th and then august 28th all things
comedy network the network that i've
started
with uh
al the daily shows al madrigal emmy
award-winning
al madrigal
you like that i have a friend that won
an emmy
i i knew i used to know al madrigal when
it was al
madrigal
now
when i talk to him i have to go excuse
me emmy award-winning al madrigal yeah
me him and uh some other guys we all
started this comedy network called all
things comedy
um
just because you know we saw podcasts
blowing up and artists always create
scenes and then they never end up with
the money the businessman comes in and
we own your podcast and we get all the
money and you get great exposure go [ __ ]
yourself have fun and behind the podcast
music on vh1 so we created like a co-op
where everybody owns their [ __ ] we all
come together
like a capsized ship trying to keep the
sharks away until the [ __ ] coast
guard comes it's called all things
comedy and we're doing a live show
our official
kickoff of this wonderful network that
i'm going to begin blogging on i've
already written a blog
um and we're going to get that up
hopefully sometime this week
and uh that's going to be at august on
august 28th at largo it's going to be
featuring as many people from the uh
the all things comedy family al is going
to be there i'm going to be there tom
pop is going to be there i believe tom
segora we got a bu and those who are
going to try to make videos it's going
to be a great night all right it's at
largo on la cienega
here in los angeles
august 28th all right back to the god
damn blood gest
um so anyways uh the past couple weeks
i've been uh talking about the food down
here in new orleans saying how delicious
slash unhealthy it is and how you can't
find [ __ ] kale
excuse me as i drink more cold water for
my [ __ ] scalded tongue
um
i actually bought a juicer this week
to somehow combat all the fried food
that i've been eating and uh i started
drinking that [ __ ] that that guy in uh
uh fat dead and kind of sick whatever
the [ __ ] is called fat sick and nearly
dead
a sick fatty with dead [ __ ] something
whatever
um
i've been drinking that [ __ ] man i gotta
tell you something it's delicious
not only is it delicious you crave it
after a while
and uh
yeah i think i dropped like four or five
pounds
good pounds too you know
the flabby ones
i was joking on twitter saying how i was
in i was in button-down shirt shape
and i actually want to get into like i
want to be in sitting down no shirt on
shape
[Music]
i don't know what i know bill cosby did
a bit on this but
he's so what the [ __ ] happens when you
sit down
you stand up and look sideways in the
mirror you're like ah you know what that
isn't bad
dare i say it's kind of cute
shows that i like the occasional
snickers
right
and you sit there pinching it yourself
like you're in an old school special k
commercial going all right that's not
that bad that's not that bad then you
just sit down and like three handfuls of
[ __ ] just lands on your thighs
you know
for the life of me i can't what is what
happens
do your hip bones move up to your
[ __ ] man tits and everything just
gets blown out i have no idea but
sitting down without a shirt on
you know that's that's the truest moment
of your [ __ ] physique that you're
gonna see all day
stop standing up sucking in your gut
all right you want to see you want to
see the damage you've done maybe you're
not ready for it
all right
this is like the ring when you looked at
that [ __ ] chick's face your jaw just
opens up and you land in a [ __ ]
walk-in closet
oh my god i don't know what happened to
me
i'm not even that bad of shape
so i said [ __ ] this i got a juicer
and um i just did a quick gig up in
chicago came right back this private
thing um
so i don't know i i ate
halfway decent up there i did find a
vegan restaurant but then of course i
had some chicago pizza
um
so now i came back and i had my little
[ __ ] grilled cheese cheese sandwich
and tomato soup so now
my body
is starting to pull me back to the the
the dark side
and that's what i've really learned
about trying to stay in shape it's all
about
keeping your brain
out in front of your body
keeping your [ __ ] wits about you
like this [ __ ] it's like
food you know when they say food is a
drug i didn't believe them but i i'm
totally convinced of it now it's like
when you're eating bad when you just go
on like a three-month bender of just
eating bad in your head like oh god i
gotta stop i want a [ __ ] cheeseburger
and you just keep going and then that
makes you want cookies and all that type
of [ __ ] it's the food equivalent to like
locking yourself in a room and just
freebasing for three months
that's what you're doing
so what i try to do when i'm eating
eating bad like this i just talked to a
buddy of mine
outside of the business who's trying to
lose some [ __ ] weight
i was trying to tell him that like you
got to keep your head out in front of it
and just go like i want that but i'm
going to eat this
even in in that moment when you're
looking at that apple as opposed to that
[ __ ] glorious
whatever you're looking at
right
toasted roast beef and cheese with the
[ __ ] pickles and the chips and all
that
the last thing your body's like that's
fi that's what the [ __ ] i want and you
gotta reach for that apple
you gotta [ __ ] hit that that
crack pipe instead
and i'm telling you the second you get
two three bites in you're like oh thank
god thank god i did that
and you're fine because from what i've
what i've read
the very little i've read your body is
it's actually craving nutrition
you know
that's why we need chinese food like
[ __ ] 35 minutes later you're hungry
again because your body's still craving
nutrition there wasn't like a [ __ ]
ounce of it in that [ __ ] at the risk of
getting sued by that entire [ __ ]
continent of china
um it's not a con
country go [ __ ] yourself
um
so that's what i would say
you could try to do that's what i'm
trying to do as i'm trying to keep my
head out in front of it so i i got that
grilled cheese sandwich and i got the
tomato soup and i said all right i gotta
get back on the [ __ ] green gumbo here
as i'm calling it because i'm in new
orleans and uh that's it i'm back on
that [ __ ] for the last two tomorrow
morning i wake up i make another one
bingo bango
i'm trying to do two a day juicing and
then one day having the [ __ ] uh
you know a healthy dinner
and then i go on the treadmill for a
half hour there's no [ __ ] way you're
not going to drop weight
all right
so there you go so stop doing those
stupid ass fad diets
it's the [ __ ] cornflakes diet all i
do is eat cornflakes i can eat as much
as i want that [ __ ]
veggie eventually
you know what really i think the really
it really is is not even like it's not
even the [ __ ] diet it's the
once you get to your weight what do you
do then
you know once you get down to your
weight at some point you're going to be
looking around it's like you got out of
jail
and there's some ice cream right over
there
you're an adult
you don't have to go mom can i have some
ice cream right
that's how you become a fat [ __ ] as an
adult there's no one to say hey you had
enough cookies it's on you got enough
boobs
put on a condom it's all on you you got
to be your own [ __ ] parent until you
get a lady in your life
then she starts [ __ ] nagging at you
take your shoes off man get out the rug
[ __ ] you lady where did you become so
angry
um
[Laughter]
so that would be my advice
when you're just on if you if right now
if you listen to this [ __ ] and you're on
a bad [ __ ] road
i'm telling you one of these days in the
future
you're going to wake up you're going to
be sitting down on the side of your bed
you're going to glance into a mirror and
you're going to be like what the [ __ ]
what have i done to myself you're going
to stand up real quick
you're going to try to suck it in and
try to deny the truth that you just saw
you hear that that's the steam engine
coming back
on the [ __ ] racist genocide 101
um
the [ __ ] am i too yeah just make
yourself eat an apple or just eat a
[ __ ] salad
you gotta you gotta turn you gotta turn
the boat around
uh that's what i'm trying to do
i gotta do it i [ __ ] went back up to
like almost a buck 90 and now back down
to like the mid 170s i got
it's the [ __ ] worst just trying to
lose like 15 pounds is the [ __ ] worst
i can't imagine people who got uh got to
lose more than that
so uh
you know
i don't i don't know how this became
more of a weight loss podcast
um but i think it's working though this
guy actually sent me a letter he said uh
podcast success story
dear wilbur
you sir are a god amongst men ah jesus i
wish that was true
he goes i used to be a depressed piece
of [ __ ]
you're uh your typical
the world is against me nobody likes me
nobody wants me [ __ ] [ __ ] that's who
i was but your advice on stepping back
and making fun of every negative
annotation i have is that a word
did he write that
do you type that correctly or my
annotation i don't know not to make you
depressed again i don't know how to
spell
um he goes i have [ __ ] changed my
life i'm 80 pounds lighter i got a great
girl and i've gotten two count them two
promotions
you're a comedian you're not obligated
to be oprah or maury but you still make
a difference thank you sir for knocking
me back into cohesion
uh you probably make 20 times more than
me i doubt that sir with your two big
promotions there
um but i know
but i owe you a drink next time i see
you if you're in canada or beantown so
you stay classy sir oh that's great good
for you sir look at that
he turned it around
somehow my
negative whatever the [ __ ] my shaming my
fat shame
my fame
has been working
um
all right enough about that [ __ ]
so that's what i'm doing i'm drinking
the i'm doing that fat sick and nearly
dead
juicing thing and uh
it's like all green stuff it's a kale
celery
a couple handfuls of parsley cucumber
zucchini and then a lime in
to take the bitterness out and uh i
gotta tell you it's [ __ ] delicious
i love it
and um
i don't know i think i'm going to
incorporate this in every couple of
months just go back to that well i'll
just juice for like four or five days
just so i stay out in front of it just
so i don't have to have to sit down one
day and have that [ __ ] beach ball i
got a thing on my button-down shirts
it's the one two third button down
when that button starts to look like
it's doing the iron cross between both
sides of my [ __ ] of my shirt that's when
i'm like ah you [ __ ] jerk off
all right and then what happens is i lay
off the beer and then i just start
slamming whiskey like that's my initial
when i've we've begun our initial
defense
into uh dieting
is i go from drinking
pale ales to whiskey
i really am a freckled mess
all right um
so anyways i had a lot of down time last
week
i wasn't working uh
i had a couple days off from uh my
episode of glee
um it's really long episode i can't
believe how long they're filming this
but uh you know i guess this is how they
do it over there i said a hell of a
budget
um
i got into uh i went on netflix and i
started watching uh ken burns the war
i know i'm like that came out like five
six years ago if you haven't seen it if
you're like me and you're late to the
party dude like that's my recommendation
for the week it's a seven potter
on world war two each one's about an
hour and 50 minutes long and i know that
sounds like i just told you to watch
every episode of lost
um
i just it's effortless to watch this
thing other than the amount of times you
have to hit pause and go jesus christ
i haven't done [ __ ] with my life that's
that's what it makes me feel like i
can't
i can't even begin to uh
you gotta you just gotta watch it you
gotta watch it and what's great
is
it really ties the whole war together
where
for me i've always seen like they'll
always do stuff on the history channel
that they'll be talking about
the war in the pacific
or they'll talk about the blitzkrieg
or they'll talk about d-day and
occasionally they'll talk about northern
africa
but this thing kind of goes in
chronological order of the whole damn
thing
and um
[Music]
it's it's
i don't know i can't explain it it would
be like
what the [ __ ] was that movie that they
showed and they showed it backwards and
the guy tattooed [ __ ] on his arm
i can't remember what the [ __ ] it was
it's like finally seeing that thing
going forwards
um
it's just
it's on [ __ ] real
what
ah jesus i'm too stupid to [ __ ] just
go just go watch the goddamn thing
watching people 17 years old lying
saying they're 18 and just going out on
the front lines and just listening to
these [ __ ] bombs whistling in seeing
all your friends getting blown up
and just just having to resign to fate
well this one's either going to hit me
or it isn't and i'm still going to be
[ __ ] shooting at these guys
um
they that the stories that they they
talk about the the guys who were flying
over on the bombardiers before they had
the escorts and [ __ ] and you had to do
25 [ __ ] missions before you know you
had basically completed your obligation
and nobody had ever made it past 14.
it's a [ __ ] suicide mission
and uh they had a guy who actually
survived the ship because he was in that
little [ __ ]
skylight at the bottom of the plane
and he got shot the [ __ ] armor went
through him and killed one of his
buddies and i don't and then he still
went back flew another one and got shot
again
and that's the thing that i that
basically saved him was because he kept
getting shot
that he wasn't physically well enough to
go back up in the goddamn plane again
and you know and i i actually have the
[ __ ] nerve
to be afraid of flying
i'm landing in [ __ ] el paso texas
going oh jesus oh gee there's nobody
shooting at us
i never felt like such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my life
to like i feel bad enough when i watch
like a ufc event
you know or i watch one of those uh one
of those shows about going to prison
you know i i watched the training for
ufc and i would be like that that i i
three times kicking that that heavy bag
with my leg it would be all bruised up
and i'd be like it stinks i want to get
out of here
it's just
can i be the guy who washes the t-shirts
can i mop up the map the
the mat that you guys wrestle on you
know
i don't know
just whatever ken burns the war and he's
done a whole bunch of documentaries and
he's doing one right now
that is uh that's about the vietnam war
and i'm all paranoid that i said his
name wrong
you know all of a sudden that sounded
like some guy in
espn but that's kenny maine right
yeah ken burns there we go all right i
got the right guy all right he's doing
right one right now
uh he's uh making one right now in the
vietnam war which i'm definitely gonna
watch you know he already made one on
the civil war
so i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ] watch all
of these things and then uh i don't know
six months later i'll forget most of it
i'll probably combine a couple two or
three wars i'll get drunk and i'll just
start spewing out information
about lincoln speaking in uh iwo jima
all right anyways let's get on with the
podcast highly recommend that if you uh
if you get a chance
if you have seven hours to kill i highly
recommend that um
if you have chicken pox it'd be a great
way to uh
forget about the itching for a good
seven hours
um
what else oh tonight oh last night
this is weird because i'm taping this on
sunday
um right now i'm taping this sunday
afternoon
new orleans time and uh i'm actually
really excited obviously
because uh
the season five i guess the second half
of seasons season five
the breaking bad premieres tonight
did i start like 12 sentences there let
me try that again
the season the second half of the season
five
series
premiere
of breaking bad starts tonight
do you guys ever wonder why i never
became a game show host as cheesy as i
am or like ever like hosted the family
feud or was
standing next next to billy bush he
entertainment like they have to read
stuff
you know i know i have the head to be on
i don't have the hairline but i do have
the head
you know ah [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
anyways breaking bad is coming back
tonight and i can't [ __ ] wait i
thought there was only five episodes you
just found out there's eight
so i'm psyched about that and um i've
already i think i've already gotten past
the sadness
that it's ending
and i'm just talking as a fan forget
about the fact that i used to you know
get in there every once in a while
um
i can't wait for this thing
to come out on box set
and uh and just go back and just
go through that whole thing again
um a couple months back i actually
watched the first two episodes
of breaking bad and just seeing when you
know cranston's character walter white
has the hair
and he's just meeting uh
jesse for the first time
do you know i heard i don't know if this
is true but i heard that jesse was
actually that character was gonna they
were gonna have him killed in the first
few but he was such a good actor
uh aaron paul that they and they liked
the character so much
i don't know if that's true i should
stop [ __ ] making up [ __ ]
i i think i remember reading this like
why would you do that bill why would you
it's one of the few bridges you can
actually cross in this business and now
you're gonna burn it by putting out
misinformation what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
um anyways i was i was somewhere killing
time
oh yesterday when i was in chicago
and i was uh in the hotel and i they had
a marathon on those doomsday preppers
and uh
they're all [ __ ]
do you know why all those doomsday
preppers are [ __ ]
is because
they're loners
they might survive some initial [ __ ]
they might last a month they might last
a year but they're just
instead of ripping the band-aid off like
me
and just getting [ __ ] you know
bludgeoned to death within the first 24
hours
[Music]
[Laughter]
or vaporized from something blowing up
that that's that's my doomsday plan
my doomsday prepping that i do
is that i live in probably the most
dangerous city that you could possibly
live in as far as earthquakes as far as
the water supply as far as the [ __ ]
inability to get the [ __ ] out of there i
really should get a helicopter license
and try to go on ebay and buy some
[ __ ] used chopper
because other than that i'm [ __ ]
but there's a
there's a piece that you gain from just
being completely [ __ ] is you're just
yeah what am i gonna do
i'm [ __ ]
all right
oh i got a great idea
i'm gonna sell
a doomsday prepper
um
[Music]
kit
for people who don't want to prep and
what it's going to be it's going to be a
a beautiful locket
that you wear they'll have a male one
it's a little more masculine put some
spikes on it or some [ __ ] male or female
and when you open it up there's one
little cyanide pill in there
there you go you just off yourself
the dollar is collapsing there's
fighting in the street you just pop it
in there
and that's it it's over
you know
you want to live and be on dead body
patrol
going out there with your [ __ ] ski
mask on having to bury all those [ __ ]
before they give out disease because
that's what you're going to be doing if
you survive if you're a low-level human
like myself where you're really not
bringing anything to the table if they
let you
survive if they decide out of the
[ __ ] blue to let you survive
that's what you're going to be that's
going to be your first [ __ ] jobs
other than getting naked and have them
throw a [ __ ] lie all over you
whatever they [ __ ] lime is that what
they throw at lie
lime all over you to get rid of the body
lice
your job you're gonna go out there
and some sort of tarzan [ __ ] bikini
bottoms
with that powdered sugar all over you
and you're gonna just start you're gonna
have
it's gonna be it
so my suggestion is
either get some cyanide or learn how to
use operate a backhoe because other than
that if you survive you're going to be
standing there with a shovel getting the
[ __ ] sunburn
that the the the the modern world has
never seen
anyways i'm watching this doomsday
prepper thing and uh
they got all these guys doing this [ __ ]
and they got this one dude
who's just
you know he's got like [ __ ] three
years
worth of [ __ ]
he's got flat screen tvs got all his
[ __ ] stuff down i love the flat
screen tv that's hilarious to me like uh
it's the end of the world but somehow
cable still exists
somehow somebody is at the the head of
the
cables cable central wherever that is
flipping the switch so you can see the
final eight episodes of breaking bad
um despite the fest
everybody connected with hollywood is
now gone
um
except for wesley snipes i'm sure he's
got a bunker somewhere
um yeah if you get the balls to not take
the government taxes you definitely got
you got you have a strategy in place
and plus just even if that [ __ ] even if
he didn't take martial arts just the
sword swinging alone that he had to
learn the choreography that would scare
the [ __ ] out of most zombies and they
turned the other way right
um
so he's got all of this stuff and he's
sitting there talking about
he's still afraid
of uh the russians in a nuclear
holocaust he's been prepping for 30
years because that's basically what they
used to scare the [ __ ] out of us about
um i came in the tail end of it in the
70s
and this guy was older than me so they
psychologically [ __ ] this guy up so
bad that he was now
you know stockpiling this hole
in the ground and then he found out that
uh recently declassified information
said that the russians had detonated
some [ __ ] i don't know 200
megaton [ __ ] something or the biggest
bomb ever detonated they did it
and he realized that he wasn't deep
enough
so he went out and he bought this big
steel [ __ ] tube
and the whole time he's doing this this
guy is like 200 pounds overweight
and it's like dude
you better
you better deal with that first like you
you're gonna drop of a [ __ ] heart
attack before they drop a [ __ ] bomb
on us and he finally addressed it he
said you know i probably should get
myself in better shape
um of course he was sitting down the
entire time and even with the t-shirt on
the guy was so [ __ ] fat you could
tell
that he was finished but uh
so i actually liked the guy because he
finally addressed the fact that he was
out of shape and needed to do something
about it
but towards the end
there was this 15 year old kid who since
the age of 12
um maybe he's a little bit older when
was 2008 that was five years ago he's
about 17. he was 12 when the 2008
uh banking collapse happened
so he went on and he the internet and he
started reading up on banks and probably
saw the conspiracy theory that i did and
it scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him as
a 12 year old
and this [ __ ] kid has been like
scavenging slash stealing [ __ ] wherever
he can because he doesn't have any money
and he has all these guns and he has
these [ __ ] swords and [ __ ] he dresses
in fatigues and stuff
and his mother is just sitting there
going like you know i always wanted a
normal thought i don't know why
he feels he has to do this and that now
he's got he's brought a friend into a
fold and then they brought a
friend into the fold and he brought a
third person into the fold and it's
literally like lady
lady did you see calling by
all right i'm not saying this kid is
like that but like what the [ __ ] are you
doing her her big parental moment was
he's not allowed to go to the gun range
without her
she goes there and lets him practice and
this [ __ ] kid was great
his spread was basically from you know
one ventricle to the [ __ ] other
right is this is there two ventricles or
is that an aorta
i don't [ __ ] know
i'll google map the heart at the end of
this
um
yeah he's basically hitting an all
center mass
right around right around your [ __ ]
heart right and
but then he goes home and he's got the
ammo and he has the guns in his [ __ ]
bedroom
and um
you know he's like i'm thankful to uh
grow up with guns he didn't even have a
southern accent why am i [ __ ] trash
in the south again
he had this [ __ ] awful haircut he
didn't have a girlfriend
he's a [ __ ] he's going down this
rabbit hole and she's just letting him
do it
and uh
i found it really disturbing
i don't find it disturbing when like i
see those kids smiling and they have
rifles and their parents have gotten
them into hunting
i know people out where i live
and when i lived in new york city they
freak out about that stuff
um
really intolerant of it
you know as they eat a [ __ ] chicken
burrito
uh
but i don't i think you should know how
to hunt and do all that type of [ __ ] you
know what i know i could [ __ ] kill i
could kill a pig
a wild boar i would love to go out and
do that
[ __ ] shoot that day
you know
now i want to hear from the rednecks out
there what what am i in for
if i miss and that thing comes up on me
don't they just start [ __ ] eating you
they're pigs right they [ __ ] eat
anything would i scare them or would i
look like one of those white
chocolate-covered pretzels
they'd think my freckles were salt
they'd be all over it
would it be okay cause since somebody
you know next time i do one of my
southern tours here can you guys take me
pig hunting
and uh i want to [ __ ] do it up
i'm gonna go rambo style with a crossbow
but i do want to have a backup uzi
and i know if you're a redneck i know
you have a [ __ ] uzi that's been
[ __ ] handed down since the the 80s
whenever the [ __ ] uzis came out before
the laws prevented you from getting them
it's for well i'm hunting quail
is this america
um
all right let's get into some questions
for the week here uh i'll read the last
couple of advertisers why don't i do
that all right here we go
had a bad first quarter i did great in
the second quarter
let's get out we got another 30 minutes
let's win this game here we go the last
couple
legal zoom everybody
most americans don't have a will but why
you don't want government rules
dictating what happens to your property
and minor children do you
so why procrastinate most people say
it's too expensive or it's too time
consuming my answer is legalzoom.com
too expensive you're gonna love
legalzooms reasonable prices too time
consuming most people finish the online
process in just 20 minutes and we're not
talking some fill in the blank bs form
here your will is state specific and
personalized based on your your
information best of all legalzoom has 12
years of experience helping people with
important legal matters
it's national make a will month
again this month
so don't wait any longer go to
legalzoom.com today and get 15 percent
off your last will but this offer ends
soon or get a living trust and you will
receive a poor overwill absolutely free
to get your special discount be sure to
enter bur b-u-r-r in the referral box at
checkout
for wills power of attorney trust and
more go to legalzoom.com legalzoom can
provide self-help services at your
specific direction or connect you with
an attorney but they are not a law firm
god dang it i had it till the end
all right
e-voice
you're screening calls closing deals and
making money all while lounging poolside
in the summer sun
thanks to e-voice e-voice is a better
way to connect with your people that
drive your business e-voice will forward
your business calls to your home mobile
or any number you choose wherever you
are e-voice will find you
um if you don't have time to take a call
it's routed to your voicemail and you
can read it at your convenience as a
text message e-voice not only gives you
an edge over your competitors it takes
away the edge the big companies have
over you right now that's a huge point
right there people i hope you were
listening with evoice you can create the
appearance of a whole office building of
departments when customers call you a
sales department customer support tech
support you name it it's gonna seem like
you have it and it works with any phone
even yourself hey it's summer don't be
stuck in your office all day free
yourself
uh with a free 30-day trial of e-voice
you can see what i'm talking about go to
evoice.com and enter the promo code bill
for your 30-day free trial that's
evoice.com promo code bill or go to the
podcast page billboard.com and click on
the e-voice banner and now it's time for
the stairway to heaven
of advertisers here
the last and final one stamps.com
everybody
pretend you have a wad of cash in your
hand now imagine
throwing it in the trash
that's exactly what you're doing when
you're leasing one of those expensive
postage meters for your uh for your
small business long-term commitments
maintenance and reset fees expensive inc
it's crazy i know a better way what is
it stamps.com everybody
what with stamps.com you get all the
benefits of a postage meter and more at
a fraction of the cost just use your own
computer and printer to get official u.s
postage for any envelope any package any
class of mail plus no more time
consuming trips to the post office
everything you do with the post office
you can do it right now from your own
desk with stamps.com i use stamps.com to
send out whatever the hell i'm selling
that week after my shows t-shirts
posters
dvds whatever you want
and if i can use it you can use it
because i am a [ __ ] and i have the uh
high school transcript to prove it right
now use my last name bur for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer it includes a digital scale
and up to 55 free postage the hell are
you waiting for
uh go to stamps.com right now before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the page homepage excuse
me and type in bur bur that stamps.com
enter birth all right there you go
there you go
went to the wild blue yonder
all right let's get into the uh the
reads for this week
italy hey bill
you mentioned a couple of weeks ago that
you were thinking about going to italy
and you wanted some advice about where
to go
my lady is italian so i've been there a
bunch of times here's the deal first you
should decide if you want to see the
north or the south
the north is more industrialized with
lots of interesting interesting cities
yeah and san marino too
all right isn't that where the blue
blood stay
uh good food and has a more vibrant
urban feel
the south is more country style with
good weather and beautiful nature i
think i kind of like that you could
think of it being very roughly like the
difference between new england and the
south back in the states and the winner
of the north will be pretty cold
and the south will be a little more
balmy they both are the [ __ ] all right
cool
and where's rome rome's like right in
the middle
i got to get to know that type of stuff
um
i can't wait to go um that's what i'm
going to do right before my european
tour
uh is i'm going to go to italy for a
couple of days like two three days why
the [ __ ] wouldn't you if you're gonna be
over there anyways i'll get acclimated
to the time
the time change while eating some of the
best food on the planet
i mean my two favorite kinds of food is
uh italian and uh japanese
those are my two favorites
i love them both
[ __ ] delish
um
so i gotta figure out where i'm gonna go
and because i only have three days
i don't wanna go there and try and do a
bunch of things
i think you just want to go there and
eat
i'm big into stadiums maybe i would see
the roman colosseum but uh
i think i just want to um
i don't know what i want to do i just
want to eat some [ __ ] just great
place
and taste really clean
food
with like what i so respect about
italians is how much they give a [ __ ]
about the food making process you know
i've told this [ __ ] before i
used to know more i used to know more
italian guys back in the day when i was
living in boston and i swear to god they
would watch me make a meal and it would
like be upsetting them and eventually
they'd just have to take over be like
just just just get out of here
it would like they would watch you
[ __ ] up a piece of meat
and it would literally it would like it
would um would upset them
you know so
you gotta respect it
all right here we go salads
oh by the way that's another great part
in the the the ken burns documentary is
um
you know i always saw mussolini given
the speeches
oh he's got one great one where he's he
keeps doing this thing with his hand
like
that
like he's just [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] like hitler makes me want
to speak german and and mussolini makes
me want to speak
italian just watching their speeches
watching hitler screaming and yelling
like you know we used to be crying
though he's soccer i'm sick of [ __ ] i
mean is that what he's saying
i want to know what the [ __ ] is he
yelling about and mussolini that look at
confidence on his face
i just want to hear what the [ __ ] he's
talking about i'm sure there's
transcriptions but it's got to be better
if you actually know the language
um and i got that [ __ ] irish thing
where i got to do everything the hard
way
um so all i would ever see was him
mussolini giving the speeches and then
him [ __ ] hanging by the meat hook him
with his [ __ ] girlfriend
um
and i always wondered what the hell had
happened i didn't know that he had
gotten captured
and then the nazis came in and freed
them
you know like the [ __ ] expendables or
some [ __ ]
is that the right reference i never saw
one of those movies but that seemed like
what they were doing like they were
rescuing people and
uh and then he got caught again and he
tried to talk his way out of it again
and his last words were
was
basically saying no
like no no no
she's just [ __ ]
christ
what a [ __ ] way to go out
you know i've been talking about that in
my act
it's just
that guy in like a year's time
he went from just like being having boy
band fame
and everybody screaming and throwing
bras at him and [ __ ] to be like on his
knees like
that
[ __ ]
they killed him and his woman
i love it too it was his mistress
i believe that's what they call i don't
[ __ ] remember i'm already starting to
forget the [ __ ] and then they brought
him into town and everybody was kicking
him and his face just they just kicked
the [ __ ] out of his face and they're
spitting on them and they hung him by a
meat hook
it's like what happened
you know you think it's bad to be like
you know in in old town
try being a [ __ ] dictator man it's
brutal it just does that's why they
never have a behind the music for
dictators because you know how it for
the most part how it [ __ ] ends you
don't end
you know you're not lying in bed
you know going through some [ __ ]
buddhist
this is the death process you know where
they teach you how to die peacefully and
you're surrounded by [ __ ] loved ones
or whatever this is the exact opposite
of that [ __ ]
hitler blew his brains out
what's his face
mussolini i just told you what the [ __ ]
happened to him
saddam hussein they dragged him out of a
[ __ ] hole he went out like a gangster
though man that jesus christ he refused
the hood
he put the rope around his neck and
he was getting heckles this is his [ __ ]
like when people talk about you know
when they go and they look at comics
getting heckled and taken on the crowd
he has to have the best one for for
dictators he was standing there
and he's getting heckled and he's giving
him [ __ ] right back with a [ __ ] rope
around his neck
you got to respect that man
i would have been like
muslin are you trying to [ __ ] wriggle
my fat head out of it
i definitely would have taken the hood
um
who else no that that the fatty over
there in a little fat boy
did korea i wonder how he died
he's probably watching like a little
house in the prairie or something he was
a weird guy
he was in the movies and [ __ ]
he actually he lived
it's very few that actually get to make
make it that far you know
they get to continue work it's like
actors who get to continue working on
into their 70s and still doing like
oscar-winning work it's very difficult
most people fall by the wayside
all right bill we get it okay all right
you know i'm into that [ __ ] all right
salads hey bill i would like to get into
eating more salads but i am only 20.
and what the [ __ ] do i know about salads
dude i don't know [ __ ] about salads i
wish i started eating salads when i was
20.
i wouldn't have this [ __ ] mess
ugh jesus christ and it's pasty it's
even worse
should i get into spinach
some good old iceberg lettuce what do i
put in salad what's the point of making
a salad if i just cover with ranch
dressing and put a bunch of bacon on it
i'm not even sure what balsamic
vinaigrette is
is a boiled egg a good thing to put in
guidance is appreciated
got to be a dick here and say ha ha
blackhawks won well you won
you get to [ __ ] brag about it you
[ __ ] um listen i don't know [ __ ] about
nutrition i'm just starting to learn
about it i know iceberg lettuce is like
90 water i think
uh spinach is good [ __ ] i like that i
like arugula
um kale's awesome
and uh
yeah
don't go through all the crap of eating
that [ __ ] and then put a bunch of
dressing on it because
you know you're adding all those extra
calories i guess balsamic vinaigrette
this is all [ __ ] that i've overheard i
heard that that's a healthier one but
even then i try to avoid drowning it
and what's great about is when you start
eating them you start craving them and
that becomes one meal a day
and that's just you know you got to
start looking at like a steak and cheese
sandwich or something like that a pizza
that's just it's just a plate full of
sit-ups
you know i [ __ ] hate going to the gym
i like going to the gym because i want
to look good i hate going to the gym
because i [ __ ] have to go which is
what i'm doing right now which sucks
you know you know what's another bad one
is when you're [ __ ] sitting up in bed
like i am and you hold your iphone up to
you and you get the reflection of like
your [ __ ] nine chins
start to get that pelican neck
anyways
so um
there's a bunch of recipes out there you
can find it but i would i'd stay away
from iceberg that stinks romaine is like
that's like halfway decent
all right iceberg
lettuce they're like the uh
i don't know
well you want you want to go sports on
this one
we'll go sports and i'm not talking
about what they're gonna do this year
what they did last year i would just say
what they've done in my lifetime all
right iceberg lettuce is like the
[ __ ] detroit lions
uh even though they're good now they
weren't then so that's probably a bad
example the cleveland browns
of lettuce sorry everybody in cleveland
although i did promote your city and i
saw a lot of [ __ ] uh construction
going on there
uh romaine lettuce is like that [ __ ]
team that every once in a while makes
the playoffs but never [ __ ] wins it
that's like the falcons
of lettuce
um
and then you get into uh arugula's the
cowboys kale i would say is the 49ers
and uh
i don't know what or i don't know maybe
i should have said the packers and
steelers
or the steelers and packers packers are
the most successful
so i'd say they're kale i'd say steelers
just shut the [ __ ] up bill okay
uh russian guy outwits banks i like this
one already
hey bill thought you might enjoy reading
this article about a russian man who
outwitted a bank by writing his own
terms into their credit card contract
jesus christ that's [ __ ] phenomenal
how the hell did
that's like beating bruce lee at karate
or kung fu
or jing funko whatever the [ __ ] you did
article here we go the idea of beating
the banks at their own game may seem
like a rich joke but dimitri
i don't know 42 year old russian man
something he plays for the red wings
doesn't he
uh 42 year old russian man may have
managed to do it unhappy with the terms
of of an unsolicited credit card offer
he received from an online bank
tincoff credit system
a garcov sorry if you're listening i'm
butchering this or if you're of russian
descent
uh he scanned the document wrote in his
own terms and sent it through the bank
approved the contract without reading
the amended fine print
unwittingly agreeing to a zero percent
interest rate
unlimited credit and no fees as well as
a stipulation that the banks
at the bank pay steep fines for changing
or canceling the contract
the bank has so much money they'll be
able to get around this boy that's
[ __ ] genius what a hero
agarkov used the card for two years but
the bank ultimately canceled it and sued
a garcah for one thousand three hundred
sixty three dollars the bank said he
owed them charges interest and late
payment fees
a court ruled that because of the no fee
no interest stipulation that garkov had
written in he owed only his unpaid 575
dollar balance
look at this
two minutes left in the game people is
he going to win this or what
agarkov is now suing the bank for 727
thousand dollars for not honoring the
contract's term
and the bank is hollering fraud they
signed the documents without looking
they said what used what usually
they said to me what usually their
borrowers say in court
we've we've not read it agarkov's lawyer
said uh
the shoes on the other foot now
sorry i really butchered the ending of
that reading so well i gotta pay
attention to that
well they'll settle out of court
i don't know man that's that's a hard i
mean the fact that
you got it just got out of paying the
fees
i got to put this in my uh my computer
here i want to pay attention to that
agarkov
russian
bank case
okay so it's still at that point hey
anybody in russia listen to this thing
can you keep please keep me abreast of
this i want to see if he gets any of
that 727 thousand dollars all right
i'm gonna do a little pregame analysis
here i'll tell you right now i got to
tell you if i'm the bank i got to be
thinking how did we end up
in this situation
i would actually guess that they're not
going to pay any of that
um they probably got enough politicians
and judges in their pockets
i mean it's corrupt enough over here i
can't imagine what the [ __ ] it's like
over there no offense but uh
it is what it is um
yeah if anybody i know in estonia latvia
if you're close enough you can pay
attention and let me know i'd appreciate
it lithuania
the ukraine
belarus look at me huh i've learned some
[ __ ] uh i'm an attention [ __ ] bill
bill burr marshall
i'm a 16 year old guy and i've recently
come to terms with the fact that i love
attention in most instances this would
not be too big of a deal i mean look at
you you made a career out of it hey
listen you [ __ ] [ __ ] just cause you
found out that you're a dick you don't
gotta rub up against me and get your
stink on me
you know
did i say i didn't like [ __ ]
attention you [ __ ]
jesus christ you know i was actually
gonna compliment you with the fact that
you actually could you could step
outside yourself
and see something that could potentially
be a flaw wanting attention is not a bad
thing it's all how you do it
you know
all right here we go i constantly sit in
class loudly cracking jokes and can
usually get the whole class laughing
plus i don't have to worry about the
teachers yelling at me because i'm such
a manipulated manipulative son of a
[ __ ] that i have
ensured that they all like me here's the
problem my friends hate it
all right this is taking a different
turn here the jokes i make with them are
far different i actually think they're
funny
you see the jokes i make to the whole
class are shitty hacky cheap cheesy
douchey jokes targeting a group laugh
the jokes i make with my friends are
normally riffing on something they might
actually be creative
all right so you kind of when you're
with your friends you're actually uh a
comics comic
but when you're in front of the crowd
you you're you're you're
playing to the masses
well you got to pick a road here son
um or maybe you don't i mean it's not
you're trying to be a comedian you know
maybe you are
if you're going to be a comedian i would
i would
try to make the crowd laugh at the jokes
and make your friends laugh
all right here we go
now
now i know the simple solution seems to
be stop being a class clown but i just
love the attention i'm so emotionally
undeveloped that i crave the craft class
approval and attention
dude you're not emotionally undeveloped
this is unbelievable that you have this
sort of uh knowledge of self at 16. i
certainly didn't what you know it's 16 i
don't think i knew till i was 36 so
you're you're in a
you're in a good situation here he goes
i love being the center of the class
making everyone laugh despite knowing
that i'm being fake and not myself
what should i do
should i stop cracking the [ __ ] jokes in
class or should i tell my friends to get
over it and keep being
that guy
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself uh first of
all i don't know what the [ __ ] your
friends have a problem with
i mean how bad are these jokes you're
saying and
you're basically what you're doing is
in class sounds like the first
i don't know three to six seven eight
years of being a stand-up comedian
where once you figure out how to make
the uh
the crowd laugh you then try to be like
well i wanna
i wanna be like say what i really wanna
talk about up here basically find your
voice
so um
i don't think that you should make a
change because of your friends i think
you should make a change because you
want to make the change
you know
when that makes sense
if you like the attention and that type
of [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
but uh if you want to take your class
clownery to the next level i would go
with some of the more creative stuff you
don't have to always go with the [ __ ]
joke but i have to commend you that you
when i used to be a class clown i would
always get in trouble and the teachers
didn't like me so the fact that you're
able to do that
is great
and uh i think you're going to be real
successful in like in life
you could do anything politics
show business sales
if you like if you can actually talk to
a crowd that that really puts you ahead
of the game
i would think all right he also says ps
as a blackhawks fan i would just like to
personally thank boston fans for being
so classy respectful and dare i say
saint light saint like from the bottom
of my heart my blackhawk heart i would
like to personally thank each and every
bruin fan you are all models of fandom
thank you for [ __ ] mocking that
um or just trying to rub it i don't give
a [ __ ] at this point that seemed like
years ago and we just won a cup so i'm
good so congratulations to you sir uh
good luck with trying to find your voice
as a class clown
all right goddamn ex-girlfriend
dear billy boy um your podcast is killer
man thanks well thank you i appreciate
that
and he says i'm writing you to get some
insight on my ex-girlfriend's situation
about six months ago my ex dumped my ass
and totally crushed my heart now that's
the worst you gotta go through it though
um he says i was [ __ ] up for a while
but took some of your advice and focused
on improving my own [ __ ] i never called
her text her or did any [ __ ]
once for six months
a couple of months ago she texts me ah
[ __ ] i knew it
i knew it
now without reading this thing she's
texted you now either she legitimately
wants to get back together with you
which if you still love her that would
be a good thing or
whatever the [ __ ] she
whatever
life path she went down over the last
six months
has hit a hard
is it a bump in the road and maybe she's
having second thoughts or maybe she's
completely evil
and she's like wow he just never called
me again why don't i call him up and
mind [ __ ] him
those are my three guesses
on the uh the [ __ ] genie lamp there
all right so she texted me she wanted to
know what i've been up to and how i was
doing
she also wanted to know why i unfriended
her on facebook
and he writes why do you think you dumb
[ __ ]
now wait a minute did you unfriend her
because of my advice or did you do that
on your own
that's a great thing you got you got to
get
cut the cancer out you can't be watching
what the [ __ ] she's doing all you're
doing is prolonging that pain in your
heart you got to uh
i'm telling you you gotta you gotta cut
off all contact and then you gotta go
chris bosh where you just gotta drop to
your knees a couple times a day and cry
it out don't be afraid to [ __ ] do
that now i wouldn't do it in front of a
bunch of men
but you know do it on your own like
as a man you have to understand that the
reason why you're able to cry is because
you're supposed to because if you don't
you keep it in your chest and it becomes
anger and then you yell at your kids
all right i resisted the urge to tell
her to go [ __ ] herself and kept my
responsible my response is cool and
casual dude you are on the road to a
post-breakup blow job
that's where you are right now let's see
if you keep the car on the road here is
my question
how the [ __ ] do broads know when you are
finally getting over them
and that they should get a hold of you
and make you feel like [ __ ] again also
do you see i knew it
also do you think it's a dick move to
get a hold of an ex
if you're the one who dumped them
when they haven't gotten a hold of you
since the breakup finally how do you
think i should handle this going forward
um
well you know what
you
you basically you learned one of life's
tough lessons
is that uh
well you know something
i might be being a dick here like maybe
guys do this [ __ ] too
all right
guys do do this [ __ ] too you got those
guys who uh they break up with the girl
but then they keep her in in
they try to like hold on to her so no
one else can [ __ ] her you know guys who
do that [ __ ] so this is really like i'm
being a sexist [ __ ] as usual
i'm coming from the male perspective
that's all i got
all right trying to show a little
empathy here
um how do they know i don't know
but they're great at it
so
rather than trying to figure it out
because
i don't know that you can as a guy just
respect that they have that ability
all right
um
you might want to consider changing your
cell phone number so she can't
text slash mind [ __ ] you again
um
what a f it's just the [ __ ] worst
they're just the [ __ ] worst in that
situation dude you just you got to walk
away from a man
so i can't remember what the [ __ ] you
asked me i'm going through all the
breakups i've been through mentally
right now
um
all right so the first thing you said is
how the [ __ ] do broads know when you're
finally over them i don't know change
your cell phone number it's my solution
um also do you think it's a dick move to
get a hold of an ex if you have no
intention of getting back with them yes
i do
and you have to accept the guilt that
you feel that you broke somebody's heart
and you have to own that you can't like
call in just calling to make sure you're
doing okay you're not helping that other
person if you have no intent you're
giving them a half a second of hope and
then
you know
you just you're you're ruining them you
got to let them go
um and lastly how do you think i should
handle this going forward yeah i would
say uh
don't respond to her texts or uh
even then just her texting you and
seeing your name and knowing that she's
thinking about you and
your heart's still going to be like well
maybe maybe somebody's getting back
together i would just change your number
start over again go bill bixby get a
backpack walk out of town
go down the [ __ ] street
um start working out get some new women
in your life that's another thing
go out there go hit kid on something he
thinks out of your league
who gives a [ __ ] go have a good time
um
hitting on a girl that's odd that's so
called out of your league is like
playing a sport
against people who are better than you
it makes you better
it ups your game
all right so then when you you play
against somebody who's only a little out
of your league you're actually you're
used to playing beyond and you're not
nervous you're used to that speed you
know does that make any [ __ ] sense i
hope it does
anyways that is the uh the podcast for
this week everybody thank you as always
for everybody who's uh contributed with
the questions and everything that really
is the last half of this podcast every
week
um
and also i forgot to mention that uh the
last couple weeks if you'd like to
support this podcast a very easy way is
if you plan on buying on something on
amazon.com just go to billboard.com
first click on the podcast page and
click on the amazon banner that we have
that'll take you right to amazon and you
don't have to do [ __ ] after that it
doesn't change the prices of anything
they kick me a percentage of uh the sale
for driving traffic their way
i take a percentage of that send it to
the wounded warriors project so it's a
two for one as far as supporting me and
supporting
the wounded warriors project and also
hard copy versions of my dvd uh my
stand-up special sorry dvd copies are
available on my website
and also available for download um for
five bucks and it's uh
the you people are all the same so
people have asked me when i'm doing
another special
i've begun talks about planning about
doing one
in the first half of next year i
basically i do them every other year
um
that's basically how it works i
spend one year having fun
writing a new hour and then i spend the
next year fine-tuning it
and then when i'm done with that then i
shoot it that's basically uh that's
basically what i do
and uh that's the formula it's been
working for me so i'm sticking with it
and then also
people in scotland have been asking me
about my am i still doing scotland
because they didn't see a date i am
definitely doing a date things got moved
around i do doing two shows in london
i'm still doing one in
scotland um it's gonna be at this
theater i forget the name of it but i'm
somewhere around the 4th of the 5th of
december or something like that
but uh hopefully at some point this week
i'm going to get an official date and
i'm gonna tweet about it i will facebook
about it and i will podcast about it
next week
and uh thank you to everybody over there
who's been buying up the tickets
it's starting off really strong
and uh
somebody actually sent me a link
um
for the uh the advertisement in
stockholm
and it was really cool it was other than
my name obviously it's all written in
[ __ ] swedish and [ __ ] it's just uh
it's the coolest [ __ ] thing ever
that there's
people on the other side of the world
speaking a different language and
they're writing about a show that you're
going to go over there and go do you
know it's [ __ ] awesome so anyways i'm
really excited about that
and all the [ __ ] that i have coming up
uh oh by the way if you're into uh if
you're not into um
motorcycle racing or you'd like to get
into it they got one of their grand prix
i think is in indianapolis or something
somewhere in the states this weekend
coming up on uh
august 18th i believe i'm actually going
to watch it now that i
got a motorcycle license i watched that
uh
documentary on netflix
about all those motorcycle races races
and that type of [ __ ] just it's just
[ __ ] the balls that that takes
it's like you're in a formula one car
except you don't have a roll cage around
you
it's unfucking real the balls that take
so i'm hopefully gonna have time to
watch it next sunday i'm definitely
going to try to find a ba out here and
once again thanks to everybody in new
orleans been having a great time coming
around town going to the open mics doing
the uh
doing the stand-up shows been getting a
wonderful reception and i've been trying
out a lot of new stuff so i'm having a
ball down here
i'm going to be down here for another
week
and
a half
and then i'm back up where the hell do i
go i go up to
connecticut to do the mgm and then i do
i think the university of cincinnati
and then i'm back out to la and that's
the deal everybody that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves
have a great week and i'll see you later
you